[Musica]
[Applauso]
ci sono oggetti che tracciano il segno
delle nostre relazioni e possono
raccontare una storia
a proposito alzi la mano chi sa che
cos'è questa cosa che in mano che usiamo
quotidianamente quasi tutti questa
marmitta questo collettore oggi una
storia è una storia fatta di terra
famiglia e sogni quando ero piccolo la
scuola devo due passioni quella di fare
aeroplani di carta e di disegnare
futuristiche supercar due idee come
sapete se nell'idea che fanno muovere il
mondo però sono poi quelli che le
realizzano che scrivono alla storia ma
io pensavo di essere uno di questi
avevo un chiodo fisso volevo vedere una
panini gt su strada nome che non è
proprio adatto il mondo automobilistico
un po per le figurine e un po perché era
famosa per quel gesto di più alla che
ancora utilizzato oggi dall'azienda la
fortuna di crescere con un padre che è
stato inventore fabbro meccanico eppure
suonatore di tromba ti fa credere che
tutto sia possibile che tutto sia
realizzabile papa aveva un fortissimo
intuito era veramente una persona molto
pratica e aveva una preparazione poco
scientifica a me piace pensare di aver
preso qualcosa da lui finito le scuole
dell'obbligo per inseguire il mio sogno
sono andato a maranello alla scuola
della ferrari e poi sono andato
all'università
ovviamente ingegneria meccanica proprio
in presto mi sono accorto che queste
università non faceva per me c'è la
passione non bastava perché l'istituto
professionale mi aveva dato molta
pratica molta manualità ma non me l'ha
dato assolutamente un metodo di studio
scientifico per un'università così
esigente e selettivo
e quindi ben presto capite la mia panini
gt su strada non avrebbe mai visto la
luce
ci rimasi molto male perché alla fine
comunque volevo lo stesso continuare a
provare in questo settore
avrei potuto andare a lavorare nelle
aziende di famiglia un lavoro sicuro
senza problemi
però alla fine ho detto no ci deve
essere una chiave a quei tempi avevo una
ragazza che poi diventata mia moglie e
scoprirò che faceva dei riassunti delle
lezioni di economia perfetti erano così
perfetti che per il mio metodo di studio
così pratico capivo dei concetti di
economia di cui nero assolutamente non
ne conoscevo assolutamente il motivo
però li capivo quindi cambia in facoltà
e laura fu ma non a quattro ruote
e così raggiunsi mio padre in azienda
agricola l'agricoltura è una scuola
unica è come la vita non si smette mai
di imparare ogni giorno perché deve
gestire cose che sono assolutamente
diverse tra di loro ma sanno e lo stesso
complementari il terreno il tempo gli
animali gli uomini e ovviamente anche i
trattori
diciamo che se vogliamo metterla in un
tono un po moderno ci sono dei contadini
che oggi sono più multitasking che
contadini che vanno veramente lavorare
proprio perché ogni giorno a devi
trovare delle idee e delle soluzioni e
poi si riaffaccia la passione dei motori
quando mio padre decise di comprare 23
macchine 23 maserati mettere
nell'azienda agricola e aprire un museo
dedicato a queste vetture e dove oggi in
questa azienda agricola produciamo
ancora un formaggio il parmigiano
reggiano
ma torniamo alle idee
se ci pensate bene c'è sempre una miccia
c'è qualcosa che ci innesca quello
strano meccanismo che ci permette poi di
collegare insieme tanti concetti che poi
diventano qualcosa di reale qualcosa di
tangibile
ma la miccia per sola non basta perché
ci vuole qualcuno o qualcosa che
l'azienda anche in maniera inconsapevole
e nella mia storia la miccia si chiama
michele una sera ero in ufficio
sul tardi entro un giovane ragazzo che
poi scopro che era un ingegnere si
chiama michela appunto e vi dice se
potevo andare a visitare la sua azienda
che operava nel mondo dell'automotive
io che sono uno molto curioso e poi
preme la curiosità è una cosa come un
motore
abbiamo sempre tenerle accese di sì
perché no dai tengo scoprì che
realizzavano dei simulatori di guida
quelli che utilizzano i piloti di
formula 1 per allenarsi
michele voleva un parere da uno di quel
mondo lo vive quello delle automobili
perché avevano delle grosse difficoltà
non riuscivano a venderli e stavano per
chiudere lo trovai ed effettivamente mi
sembra di essere un pilota di formula 1
forse anche troppo perché forse la
ricerca di queste realtà così esasperati
di questa realtà virtuale aveva reso
l'oggetto troppo professionale e quindi
io gli consigliai di rendere l'oggetto
molto più giocattolo e gli dissi guarda
secondo me tu lo dovreste completare
dovresti metterci le ruote
dovresti mitici l'elettore poi scusa
siamo nella terra dei motori fai finta
che ci sia un motore dentro mettici 2
marmette e fa uscire il suono delle
marmitte mentre veniva a casa dice o
zakis ti devi far suonare le marmitte
proprio bella alla mattina dio internet
mi collego e scopro che non c'era
assolutamente nulla
avevo trovato milioni di impianti audio
quelli fatti con le canne di bambù con i
bidoni con tutte le rob usate di tutto
ma non c'era niente che era collegate le
marmette quindi presi tra i miei rottami
una vecchia marmitta di una ferrari di
formula 1 e andai da massimo un mio
amico elettrauto e disse sentimenti mini
dentro degli speaker farmela suonare
dopo qualche giorno massimo mediano e
diseguale matteo è impossibile i
diametri sono troppo piccoli e le casse
dentro non ci stanno
impossibile impossibile voi sapete che
noi modenesi comunque abbiamo nel nostro
stemma del nostro della nostra città c'è
scritto avia pervia detto impossibile è
impossibile
ci vuole un'idea
quindi pensai che vi viene l'idea di
creare una struttura che separasse la
marmitta dallo speaker e di utilizzare
la marmitta come camera di risonanza per
lo speaker stesso in poche parole capi
ben presto che la marmitta con la sua
forma influenzava veramente il suono
dello speaker poi potete immaginare la
gioia di quando vidi i primi bozzetti
disegnati da mirko mio amico designer
perché mi sembra
mi sembra di essere tornati sui banchi
di scuola a disegnare le mie improbabili
supercar
ovviamente non è un impianto audio ma è
qualcosa di più perché di un oggetto
iconico come la marmitta rappresenta
tutti i più bei valori che la gente
della mia terra sa esprimere la passione
la velocità d'azione e la voce dei
motori non è ovviamente un automobile
non è tanto meno la panini gt però delle
automobili che sono costruite o a modena
racchiude tutta la filosofia
il design l'artigianalità la cura per i
dettagli e la personalizzazione quindi
dalle marmitte non faccio più uscire i
suoni caldi del motore la faccia uscire
la musica e pensate che questa idea è
stata anche brevettata e così per me si
è chiuso un ciclo
sono ritornate all'inizio sono ritornati
alle mie origini sono tornate alla mia
terra alle mie biol che i miei problemi
e le mie soluzioni
e così oggi la voce dei motori coesiste
con la voce della terra quella che noi
qua modena orgogliosamente chiamiamo
tutti i giorni la terra dei motori
ogni giorno sarebbe utile farsi venire
in mente un'idea ma bisogna crederci
perché se non ci si crede
l'idea rimane quello che è un idea e
basta
[Applauso]